- It's still going into
talking about mental health,
especially right now.
I think we're all like
everyone on the planet
is playing some kind of mental game,
you know, at some point,
just because it's, you're so isolated,
your world has completely
changed from your daily routine
and your kids are, you know,
if you have kids in your house,
that's a whole other thing and they,
and those poor little dudes,
they're all like, they're,
they're just running around
going what's happening.
My mom,
my little six year old is like,
is there sickness still happening?
And I'm like, no.
- Yeah.
You know, for a minute,
when quarantine had first started,
I was hiding my emotions from my kids
because I didn't want them
to see mom kind of like
- Yeah.
- you know all over the place.
I always say that I'm kind
of like bipolar, right?
One minute I'm like, yeah, I got this,
and then the next minute, I'm
like, no, I don't got this,
but I found that holding it in--
- I think that's called
being human and a mom,
but--
(laughing)
- Thank you girl,
but yeah,
but I found out that when
I was just holding it in,
I remember I had meditated
for the first time
during quarantine, which had been a while.
I was just like focusing on
everybody else and not myself,
you know what I mean?
And moms tend to do that a lot
and I just started crying.
Like everything just
started to just, you know,
let go and release.
And it was very,
it was very healthy for me.
So my point in sharing that story is,
you know, during this time,
if anybody, you know, wants some advice,
especially when it comes
to your mental health,
number one know that you are worth it.
You know what I mean?
Know that you are worth
taking that time out
to give yourself some sort of self care
and that's exactly what you know I did.
And it, and it really helped me.
And it's helping me during this whole,
this whole crazy situation
that we're in right now
is just taking time out,
you know, for yourself.
- And I think, I think you're right.
I think moms,
especially just in my experience
with moms and dads I know,
it's, it's more than moms that always
we, we are so worried about
everybody else's stuff
like their mental health,
how they're doing,
checking in with them,
- Yeah.
- making sure their needs are being met
and you we are the last
ones that we look at.
And that is so disruptive,
not just for you,
but your family as well.
- That's a great perspective.